l'Agence météorologique mondiale qui en
deux mots vous vient de l'entendre lance
la serviette dit il y a plus rien à
faire les glaciers vont fondre j'ai deux
questions pour Jean Lemire qui est avec
nous qui a eu la gentillesse de venir
avec nous Jean bonsoir émissaire au
changement climatique aux enjeux
nordiques etc vous connaissez bien ces
choses je dis j'ai deux questions est-ce
que sur l'accélération dans quelle
mesure ça s'accélère ça nous étonne même
tellement que ça va vite et l'autre
question ce sera sur les impacts mais
d'abord est-ce qu'il est vrai
que oui là mais que on est même étonné
par le rythme de fonte
bonsoir d'abord Patrice oui en fait
malheureusement c'est le même message
que l'on répète depuis 25-30 ans vous
savez l'accumulation des gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère
handicap vraiment notre position pour
quelques décennies à venir j'ai toujours
dit que d'ici 2040 c'était déjà plié là
donc même si on faisait des gains
énormes d'ici 2040 on ne verrait pas une
diminution de l'augmentation ce que l'OM
dit aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
probablement jusqu'en 2060 c'est vrai ça
va plus vite pour les glaciers c'est pas
mal réglé ce sera extrêmement difficile
à moins qu'on réussisse un peu par
miracle à retiré du CO2 de l'atmosphère
mais ça Patrice les techniques ne sont
pas très efficaces elle coûte très cher
elles sont faites un petit échelle et
c'est souvent un sauf conduit pour des
entreprises qui ne veulent pas faire
leur part
non j'avais dit quand vous dites c'est
réglé vous êtes ça presque en passant
mais qu'est-ce que veut dire c'est réglé
tous les glaciers
ceux qu'on connaît vont fondre
en fait la fonte elle est spectaculaire
si on regarde depuis 1970 si on fait une
moyenne les glaciers qu'on a étudié le
plus dans le monde ont perdu 30 mètres
c'est énorme et donc on est là pourquoi
on dit que c'est un peu réglé c'est que
depuis Paris avez-vous vu une diminution
de nos GES absolument pas ça continue
toujours d'augmenter donc à un moment
donné il faut bien se rendre oui ce
serait possible moi je vais vous faire
une autre annonce qui est pas très très
joujou le 1.5 il est pas mal réglé on
est déjà à un point 15 Patrice donc si
on avait une diminution drastique des
gaz à effet de serre je vous dirais on
est on s'en va la bonne direction mais
c'est pas le cas en ce moment on a fait
des gains si on compare quand on était à
Paris là en 2010 on s'en allait vers un
réchauffement qui faut atteindre 5 6
degrés on a diminué ça à 3 c'est une
diminution de l'augmentation mais c'est
pas une diminution réelle et donc c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu c'est que l'on
dit aujourd'hui pour les pour la plupart
des glaciers c'est un peu réglé le train
infernal on réduit sa vitesse mais
continue à avancer là c'est ce que vous
dites exactement mais là les glaciers
qui fonde comme ça c'est quand même très
grave et ça désimpact énorme bon oui ça
fait monter les océans quoi d'autre
qu'est-ce qui doit nous préoccuper le
plus
moi je vous dirais que vous savez si on
regarde ce qui contrôle un peu la météo
puis là je vais vous faire des grandes
images là qui sont pas précis ensuite
mais on dirait 50% et contrôlé par les
grands vents atmosphériques et 50% par
les grands courants océaniques or c'est
grand courant
océanique qui vont de l'Antarctique qui
passe et qui viennent jusqu'ici avec le
Gold stream et tout ça cette vitesse de
courant elle est due à une différence de
densité de l'eau donc l'eau qui est
beaucoup plus lourde sur tous vos fonds
l'eau plus douce en surface et donc
c'est cette différence qui active la
grande pompe des grands courants qui
fait le tour de la planète or si vous
amenez plus d'eau douce par la fonte des
glaciers ben évidemment vous venez
changer cette densité et donc il y a un
risque de ralentissement de ce qui est à
50% la machine climatique mondiale donc
c'est énorme prenez aussi ce qu'on
appelle l'effet d'albedo l'effet c'est
l'effet miroir si vous avez une surface
blanche et que vous envoyez des rayons
du soleil ça va agir comme un miroir et
la majorité de l'énergie va être
renvoyée donc elle ne sera pas absorbée
mais là si vous remplacez ça par une
surface noire foncée cette énergie-là va
être captée et là évidemment on accélère
encore tout davantage donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est vraiment dans une situation et
dernier point Patrick mais il est très
important quand on dit qu'on se dirige
vers une augmentation de 3 degrés c'est
à l'échelle planétaire pour le sud du
Québec on parle du double on parle de 6
degrés 6 degrés si vous là on est à un
coin 15 vous voyez tous les effets sur
le climat etc essayez d'imaginer 6 donc
on est vraiment dans une situation où ça
va beaucoup plus vite que l'on pensait
on va boire un verre de vin de plus on
est un petit corail parce que vous
l'avez bien dit Jean-Louis
si on était en train de diminuer à
l'échelle de la planète les GES
rapidement mais parlons juste du Canada
on n'a pas encore diminué on dit qu'on
va commencer à diminuer
on a augmenté encore
on voit pas très bien donc on va se
tourner de plus en plus vers
l'adaptation à ces gros changements là
inévitablement inévitablement Patrice
parce que on est déjà dans une période
on le voit là évidemment ça bouge
beaucoup il y a beaucoup d'impact avec
la météo si on investit pas dans
l'adaptation au changement climatique on
va avoir évidemment des conséquences
catastrophiques
investir maintenant un dollar dans les
dans la captation au changement
climatique risque de nous en faire
sauver 8 10 à long terme donc il faut
déjà commencer à penser à l'adaptation
tout en continuant à essayer évidemment
de diminuer
le train parce qu'on le ralentit pas on
sera encore moins adapté ça va aller
encore plus vite exactement exactement
du Québec entre autres scientifiques on
vous connaît bien salut à la prochaine
merci Patrice à la prochaine